rhod bud is the safety supervisor and is
responsible for bringing these
scientists back home alive fanzones
citizens in the water he'll be the first
one in to ensure conditions are safe
for the rest of the team without
protective clothing ice-cold waters can
knock a person unconscious within
minutes while this team is wearing well
insulated dry suits their heads are
almost completely exposed this is just a
quick test dive but when the real
mission begins the dive team will only
get 40 minutes to finish the job
35 minutes we give four folds we would
call the diver safe sighs pretty much
over down here robe signals are the only
way to call for help but as the body's
core temperature decreases
one of the first handicaps is loss of
dexterity and at these temperatures
regulators can quickly malfunction and
drain the divers air supplies
[Music]
thanks off cuckoo so well okay my
interns become it does drop your whole
core temperature that little bitter
until his body temperature returns to
normal
rod is prohibited from going back down
[Music]
you